so um our last topic today I actually
wanted to pull a clip of Candice Owens
critiquing Taylor
Swift why why can't people see this now
why does this frustrate me because I
talk about this all the time we are also
facing a crisis where adults want to
behave like children and children want
to behave like adults and people think
this is cute it's not this is not how
34-year-old women behave we don't come
up with secret handshakes we don't hip
bump each other that is childish it is
theatrical it should never be seen I
have such an issue with this it just
makes me cringe every inch of my body
every time I watch it it makes me cringe
okay
so my question is what is it with
Candice and fighting with blonde chicks
I I was looking this up it was like her
ex-best friend she like ambushed Tommy
Lauren Megan Kelly now now Taylor Swift
is wrong for like H checks
notes hip bumping
somebody and I I like Candace Owens
she's got a lot of good takes but why
why does this woman start beef with
every woman over
nothing what her let me get this
straight and I and there's a lot to
criticize Taylor Swift about if we want
to talk about her
ex-boyfriends um making face basically
hitpiece albums on all of them fine we
want to talk about the victim mentality
culture the leftism fine but her crime
is let me let me let me check notes
check notes does a a
handshake does a
handshake at
a football game now look maybe maybe I'm
just a big ball of fun okay I I don't
see anything wrong with a hand handshake
all right I just I don't think it's the
end all be all I don't even think it's
worth covering and the comments were
actually kind of against her on this
like to be honest most of the time the
comments kind of back what Candace is
saying but she's saying the worst kind
of person is someone who makes someone
feel bad dumb or stupid for being
excited about something Taylor Swift and
I almost think we're we're too serious
as a society like it's okay to have fun
do a stupid handshake who cares you know
you do that The Shake It Up song um VA
Nana excuse me we need more of this in
our lives yes fun laughter love you are
never too old for that Natasha the way
you talk about her is cringe you have so
many issues with Taylor Swift yet you
talk about her a lot find other content
to talk about Candace yeah I'm just like
what is it with I saw her arguing with
Megan Kelly okay and I saw her doing the
same thing Megan Kelly was talking about
how you shouldn't hire these like woke
young people and then Candice comes in
and she's say saying oh well what like
she starts going after Megan Kelly
someone she pretty much agrees with
because Megan Kelly doesn't want to hire
woke young people and then she brings up
an exception which is kind of a female
way to argue where she says what Megan
Kelly well I used to be a leftist now
you're just as bad as the left like
Candice clearly Megan Kelly is not
talking about you the exception most
women go on to become more and more
liberal we cannot have
conversations if we are always bringing
up the exception so I've just I've just
noticed I'm like what is it with this
chick and going after these like pretty
blonde chicks it was like Tommy Lauren
was another one um her that that
comedian I can't remember her name but I
I don't know I disagree with this take I
I think there's nothing wrong with doing
a handshake at a football game and I I
can't even believe I'm bringing this up
on a show okay guys to close out the
show we are going to be reading the top
comment from the last Pearl daily
episode if you want your comment to be
considered leave it in the comments
section below and make sure you are
liking your favorite comment so the top
comment last time was from Orange and
Slinky we don't want tattoos or nose
Bull Rings or fake eyelashes we don't
want tons of makeup we want thin women
too see how simple that is and it is
very very simple thank you orange and
Slinky guys make sure you like the video
on your way out get get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today and I will
talk to you next time